the one a million nation
I asked Lily from Tirana dance Elsa to
join me on this video and today we're
going to learn about how to love
yourself
one of the most important things I've
learned in my life is the importance of
loving yourself when I do like
motivational speeches or even telling
myself love yourself and you should love
yourself
I will where it comes across very cliche
you might tell myself I'm like okay
I sound like a tumblr quote but really
if you actually think about it a lot of
us don't love ourself and it's like the
most important thing we should do on a
daily basis because nobody knows our
needs as well as we do no one knows our
thoughts are honest genuine thoughts and
fears as well as we do people who are
always a guy need to be in relationship
and I can't be alone and they feel
uncomfortable being alone it's probably
because they don't love themselves and
they don't know how to be comfortable
being alone and being with themselves
you can't be part of it too if you're
not a complete one and I think it's so
important to be comfortable with
yourself know your strengths weaknesses
talk to yourself and be friends with
yourself I literally talk to myself I'm
super super lame I love all people my
life don't get me wrong but I just feel
like if you don't love yourself none of
your other relationships can work
because the relationship yourself is
most important it's like a huge
reflection on how other people treat you
if people treat themselves poorly but
that's an indication to other people
like oh she treats herself poorly and I
can also treat her poorly how we treat
ourselves is a projection to other
people okay I love myself and I know how
I should be treated and I should be
treated well and therefore I will not
accept not being treated well by
everyone else
I love me so with the day that you
decide to stop loving me I'm not gonna
love myself any less I believe in me if
you stopped believing in me
I'm not gonna believe in myself any less
if you believe that I'm irrelevant that
no one is checking for me and that I
don't mean anything to the world because
you think or believe that about me
it doesn't believe it doesn't mean that
I'm gonna believe it about myself see
the day that you start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion is
the beginning of the end most of y'all
and it's up I see it every day all day
most of you guys don't actually know
your self-worth you don't know your self
value so you're like a vulnerable little
child and you're you're shaking and it's
like everybody loves me this week so I
love me this week next week it drops so
now you're running around insecure
feeling self-conscious and not loving
yourself sad and depressed
based on the feedback the responses and
the energy that the rest of the world is
giving you I wrote about this in my new
book which is coming it's called black
rose it hasn't been released yet but
it's coming I talked about the fact that
Fame is an addiction fame is one of the
most unspoken addictions out there so
many celebrities and entertainers
athletes and public figures they base
their self-worth on their relevancy
based on everybody in the world checking
form and as soon as people stopped
checking form then they stopped checking
for they self y'all don't love me no
more I'm not selling records I'm not
number one in the box office no more I'm
not making as much money as I used to
make oh ain't nobody checking for me so
guess what I'm
not checking for myself no one sees the
value in me anymore so I don't see the
value of me anymore every time I go on
Twitter Facebook they say I'm irrelevant
so I'm irrelevant to myself now I ain't
because you think that I ain't no one
loves me because you said no one loves
me I don't love me the day that you
allow the opinions of the outside world
to dictate the way you feel about
yourself
it is the beginning of the end of you
living a blessed and self loving secure
life I can tell y'all right now that it
is not the car that I Drive or any de
jure that I own or the size of my house
that defines my self-worth I'm hot I'm
hot I'm hot when you don't think I'm hot
I'm amazing when you don't think I'm
amazing I love me even if you stop
loving me
you can say the nastiest meanest evilish
that you could have a conjure up it will
never change the way I feel about myself
I'm telling you that's the way I live my
life that's how I feel about me most of
y'all are on Twitter you're desperate
for likes you're desperate for the the
egotistical feeding frenzy feed my ego
Fifi feed like me like me because I
don't like me I'm telling y'all right
now
the day that you allow the opinions of
everybody on the outside world to define
your day to day month a month and year
to year it's the beginning of the end
love yourself believe in yourself love
yourself believe in yourself independent
of the validation of the world have
opinions and feelings about yourself
independent of the feedback why you got
to have somebody calling you beautiful
every day in order for you to feel be
do you believe that you're beautiful or
do you only believe you're beautiful
when other people say that you're
beautiful
I'm just asking self-love is the cure to
self hate if you make it to the end of
this video I want you to write self-love
is the cure to self hate these are the
type of qualities that I'm going and
have been in stealing in my daughter
there is no man that you could ever meet
Shayla that can make you feel more
amazing than what you're supposed to
feel about yourself nobody wants to be
alone but if you show up empty as an
empty shell and you're expecting this
man to fulfill you and fill you up with
all a little love that doesn't exist
you're gonna be tough because as soon as
he leaves you depleted you're empty and
you have nothing left for yourself again
never rely or depend on anybody to
fulfill your heart and if you don't
believe in the Lord Jesus Christ you
better get to know him because that's
also a part of the process of self-love
you are supposed to love yourself
independent of any feedback comments
likes shares in any of all of these
other social medias some of y'all are
social media [ __ ] what does that mean
I I ain't [ __ ] until people on my
timeline tell me that I'm I love me
independent of anything that anybody
could ever say has nothing to do with
being arrogant egotistical it's just a
matter of knowing and being aware of
self-worth I love you if you make it to
the end of this video I want you to
write self-love is the cure to self hate
self-love is to cure to self hate and I
hope you share this video because I want
this video to spread all over the world
send it to WorldStarHipHop send it to
all of the blogs and the websites
self-love is to cure the self hate sure
man Tyreese spreading love always share
share share click that share button
spread love love circle I love you
always know I know that you've heard me
say many
or you've read or listened on the tapes
that loving yourself is the most
powerful thing we can do then everything
flows everything flows beautifully and
I'm not talking about vanity or
arrogance because that is not love
that's always fear I'm talking about
just really respecting and appreciating
this incredible magnificent being that
we are you know little babies know how
to love themselves you were born in pure
love all of you there's not one little
baby alive I that I know of that ever
criticizes its body wherever says my
hips are too big
have you ever heard a baby say that
they're just thrilled and delighted that
they have a body they rejoice in it and
they love themselves they love their
toes they love everything about
themselves they absolutely adore that
they express their feelings you know I
mean a baby is happy you know it when a
baby is angry the whole neighborhood
knows it
they're never scared to let people know
how they feel they live in the moment
and they're filled with courage and
they're wonderful and we were all like
that gotta remember that you were filled
with courage and you were full of love
and you adored yourself when you were
very little and then what happens is we
start to grow up and we start to listen
to people that were frightened or
critical or resentful or guilty and many
of us grew up with people like that
you know if you grew up in a family
where there's criticism was the norm
then you're gonna grow up to be a
critical person you're gonna look at
everything in life as with criticism and
you probably criticize yourself and
other people and you won't enjoy life
nearly as much as you could if you grow
up in a family where you were not
allowed to express anger then either
you're a person who is terrified of
anger or you swallow it down all the
time and you let it sit in your body if
you were grazed in a family where
everybody was manipulated by guilt then
you're probably gonna do the same thing
you're probably a person who runs around
saying I'm sorry all the time I'm sorry
I'm sorry and you could never ask for
anything out right because you always
want to manipulate somebody but these
are old family patterns
and it's very easy to blame our parents
and it's very easy to blame our
childhood or our environment but the
problem with that is that it keeps us
stuck we don't get to be free we get to
stay in our victim thing and that's no
good for anybody then we just get to
keep having our problems but remember
you're in charge now doesn't matter what
your parents
doesn't matter what anybody else did
doesn't matter what you learned what
really matters is what you are choosing
to think and say now because you're the
only person that thinks in your mind and
you choose your thoughts now I can tell
you lots and lots of wonderful things
but if you don't choose to listen to
them then they're not gonna work at all
so you are always in charge and you're
creating your world and your life now
I've known that one of the most powerful
affirmations you can use is I love and
approve of myself I love and approve of
myself and when you first say that it's
amazing what can come up and come to the
surface
lots of times when we begin to say that
all the negative messages come to the
surface and it's marvelous because that
gives us an opportunity to know what's
been in the way you see if you don't
hear your negative messages you don't
know what's in your way so when you
start to do an affirmation like I love
and approve of myself you want to really
pay attention to what the negative
messages are because they're the ones
that are in the way and when you find a
negative message if you could write it
down it's wonderful because you want to
think I found a treasure this is
something that's really in my way and
really creating a problem remember we
get to choose the way we think and we
can choose to change the way we think
it's always our choice now what I'd like
you to do right now is take out those
little mirrors that you have I know
everybody has a little mirror
okay good now let's see if you can look
in your eyes without primping see if you
can manage to do that I want you to look
in your eyes and I want you to say I
love you I love and approve of you
exactly as you are
okay now just begin to notice what
you're feeling don't judge it just
notice what are the feelings that are
coming up are they feelings of joy do
you feel you feel wonderful about
yourself
are they feelings of criticism or
negativity don't judge though just
notice what they're coming up
acknowledge the negative message just
acknowledge it and you can always say
thank you for sharing and realize that
the negative messages that are coming up
now are very much the things that are in
the way of you loving yourself okay what
I want to do right now is let's do it
just a little bit of sharing okay I want
to know what sort of messages are coming
up from you hmm yes fear would be upset
if you really loved yourself me no no no
no no no it always goes back farther it
would be upset if you really loved
yourself
my parents your parents which one both
of them you know okay finally missing
what was the family message Oh always
judgmental always aha and okay so you
know critical judgmental resentful
family right okay fine so your and
wonderful and fearful oh boy you really
got it all okay it just means that you
have a little more to work on you know I
really think that some of us are very
young Souls and we come here and it's
like going to kindergarten life is
really very simple and some of us are
much older Souls and we pick tougher
tests and it's more like going to
graduate school but you know you can do
it it's just that you've chosen perhaps
a little more difficult things to
overcome but see it's my belief that the
main thing that we really come here to
work on is loving ourselves in spite of
what they say
and in spite of what they do and that's
what we really need to do so oK you've
got things you've got credit you've got
judgments you've got criticism you've
got fear
probably a little guilt in there too
okay
then you you I I like to always think of
that we can go beyond our parents
limitations you know they had a limited
way of looking at life and you were a
very good little child so you learned
what they taught you so you lose a lot
of us think that we're bad and we're not
good enough and we're no good but
actually we're ideal wonderful loving
little children and we learn exactly
what our parents teach us not always
what they tell us to do but we learn
from them and we learned exactly what
they do and we grow up doing the same
thing loving yourself how to do it is
all about investing in your happiness
whatever makes you happy make time for
it don't take life so seriously because
where you feel most free is where you
find your greatest power you begin to
love yourself the passion arises within
you once again many people do not love
themselves because they do not love what
they are doing if you don't like
yourself then ask yourself the following
question do you really not like yourself
or do you not like an aspect of yourself
big difference right is it you all of
you that you don't like or just an
aspect I bet it's just an aspect so if
that's the case first of all realize how
much you're focusing on it right and I
want you to take that camera that you
have right now and you're totally zoomed
in on this one imperfection that you
have you're totally zoomed in on it I
want you to zoom out and see yourself
and your whole life
and the whole history that you have of
your life and where you're going see all
of that and put that in perfection that
one imperfection is a context right it's
still there I'm not denying it it might
not be there maybe you have some crooked
teeth or you have a big nose or you have
a fat ass or whatever or maybe you have
some you know character flaws in you not
physical problems but character flaws
and you don't like yourself for those
reasons okay let's admit that that's
there let's say that it's true it's
there well that's that's one aspect of a
much bigger picture so first of all
realize that that's the case and if that
is the case then also realize this point
is that you have a choice of what you
focus on you you've got this you've got
this like laser beam in your mind which
is your focus right your awareness and
this laser beam it's it's consciously
guided by you not all the time but you
can guide it and so if you're always
hating on yourself then what you're
doing is you're taking your
imperfections and you're always like
shining a magnifying glass over it
that's what's happening you're shining
this magnifying glass on your
imperfections sometimes all you do is
you just stare at them all day right and
that's why you feel so bad about
yourself sometimes because you stare at
those imperfections ceaselessly well if
you've got an imperfection there's that
you only got two choices either you're
gonna fix it either you can change it or
you can't now go out there and try to
change it if you can I mean that's what
I'm all about I'm giving you a lot of
advice and stuff with all my videos
about you know how to put your life into
place may actually make it really good
objectively good but if you can't change
it maybe like your physical appearance
you can't you feel like you can't change
it or you don't really want to go that
far
then that's fine you can then learn to
accept it in the sense that you're gonna
shift your focus away you're gonna kind
of accept it and not look at it anymore
stop looking at it because it's the cost
of looking at it and the relooking and
the real looking and the real looking
that is that's really killing you you're
gonna start to focus on other areas of
your life that are great and what you're
gonna realize when you make that shift
is you're gonna realize that well that
little imperfection it's not that
important anymore and then maybe a
couple of years down the road you will
actually laugh you will laugh because
you'll laugh and say how could I have
possibly been so concerned about that
it's so insignificant now because I've
got all this other awesome stuff
flourishing in my life I'm reading a
book called super you and it talks about
your origin story your origin story is
your your most weakness right every
superhero has one Batman lost his
parents when he was a young kid well
because of that it gave him great
strength so remember where you come from
remember who you are there's seven
billion people on this planet and out of
all those people you are unique and
you're very special and the more you
recognize that the more self-love you're
going to have for yourself so what do
you think so I think there are two
important things when it comes to loving
myself the first thing is really really
knowing who I am so if I'm really really
self-aware I know myself inside out I
know what my weaknesses are as well as
where my strengths are then that way I
could always lean into the strength and
if you know yourself extremely well then
you could actually go into really deep
and love yourself unconditionally
because I believe that if you don't know
yourself wholeheartedly you cannot love
yourself fully and then the second thing
is the negative self-talk you know
saying that I'm ugly I'm stupid all that
kind of stuff needs to end because you
will not talk to someone you love a lot
that way so stop the negative talk and
the self-criticism I love it I think for
me I think I've always loved myself I
think when I kind of took it up an extra
level extra notch is when I really found
the work that I loved and felt like I
was doing important stuff and so it
encouraged you guys whatever work you're
doing make sure you're doing it for
yourself even the the relationship that
you're in make sure you're doing it for
yourself as well as for the other people
around you and I think when I started to
have the courage and confidence to stand
up for myself when somebody didn't
believe in my idea where I wanted to
start this business where I want to make
this video or I wanted to chase that
opportunity and somebody said that's
really stupid and I stood up to them and
say you know what I'm gonna do it anyway
that started to make me have more
confidence and more love for myself I
think you can only do that when you
really love the work or the project that
you are trying to get into so the more
I've done that the more the muscles
built up but now the more
confidence I have the more I love myself
I think the other thing if I the second
point would be creating an environment
that is loving for yourself if you don't
love yourself right now chances are you
know your parents and love themselves
your friends don't love themselves and
so tied into the negative self-talk is
what are the what are the resources that
you have around you what videos are you
watching what books you're reading what
music are you listening to who are your
friends the more that you can surround
yourself and create a more loving
environment for yourself the more likely
that's going to now be your new reality
instead of sticking to that self-hate
and negative talk
so thank you guys so much for watching
we made this video because Python asked
us if there's any videos or topics you
want Evan to cover just leave in the
comments below I'd also love to know
what you thought of this video what was
your favorite point is there anything
that you want to add about how to love
yourself leave it down the comments
below and we will join in the discussion
so thank you guys so much for watching
we believe in you we hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
we'll see you soon
you